welcome back to new rockstars this is a
big question the show that gives you too
much information about your doppelganger
and how to kill them how to hunt them
down and find them because he's looking
for you because you look just like
my name is jessica clemens uh with me
today is ice cream producer brandon
beard oh i don't sound so shocked i'm
sharp because where are we where are we
where are we you might be asking
yourselves that very question at home
right now well we're doing the bq today
from a very special location that's
right this is the set for our new daily
live show the break room whoa a new
daily live show it's actually premiering
tomorrow on the channel right here in
the afternoon oh my god uh i'm gonna be
on it jessica's gonna be on it uh you'll
see off-screen producer zach on the show
you'll see uncle tommy bechdel on the
show
maybe some appearances from philip
molina maybe appearances from whitney
van langham who knows all sorts of
guests are gonna come on it's gonna be
great this isn't you know the permanent
uh bq set at all we're gonna have a new
bq set eventually but this is the break
room set you're getting a little preview
right now and we're so excited to be in
person no longer trapped at our blue
dungeons uh we're we're in touching
distance very safely of course yeah what
are they going to see on the break room
what are we going to talk about on the
break room oh my gosh we're going to
talk about all the nern news and
up-to-date stuff that you guys have been
asking for we are only here to bring you
everything in nerd culture whether
that's in dc mcu star wars stranger
things uh everything everything and
we're gonna tell them about it every
single day yeah we'll be here every
weekday uh we're gonna interact with the
chat a ton we're gonna do doing lots of
fun stuff with the chat so you can talk
to us you can ask questions we'll answer
the questions we'll have some fun every
now and then some of it will be
mandatory fun uh but it will be fun so
check us out every day here on the
channel streaminglive and if you missed
the live stream you can always watch it
later and catch up on everything so you
won't miss a minute uh so yeah check us
out tomorrow as we go live 3 p.m pacific
maybe have to cut that out who knows
very flexible we don't know sometimes
things change you don't know when
another earthquake might happen that's
right check us out tomorrow 3 p.m
pacific 6 p.m eastern
11 p.m if you live in the uk uh all over
the world you'll be able to watch us uh
so tune in and check that out so today
we're here with big question because
that's what you guys are tuning in for
so what is our big question for today
i'm glad you asked jessica i'm glad you
asked well we finally got a trailer for
thor love and thunder uh and with it
came our first look at the back of zeus
we didn't see the front of zeus we saw
the back of zeus as well as what we can
assume is the pocket dimension home of
all the greek gods olympus wait a second
jessica didn't the eternals like already
establish some of greek mythology that
that these space robots were the greek
gods that they're the ones that were on
mcu's are doing this not the the real
gods living in olympus like right yeah
isn't that what they did oh so sorry but
side note now that we could do this in
person i didn't notice how much you play
piano
that's what keeps me on tennis
piano jessica
can we ask this question
billy joel is shuddering right now oh
stop it he's gonna get his minivan he's
gonna come find me let me do my show for
christ's sake
but aren't all the god like not all the
guys but most of the gods and eternals
technically yeah they kind of set that
up right that like they were the
legends that became the mythology to the
people who lived on mcu's earth so
that's what leads us uh to this week's
big question how do the eternals history
and the greek gods history fit into the
mcu
right that's a great question that's a
good big question to have so many of us
here at the new rockstar's office we've
been wondering how these two versions of
greek mythology would mesh together as
soon as we saw those golden lightning
bolts appear in the thor teaser
because here come the olympians baby
they're coming into marvel finally
they've existed in marvel comics for
quite some time the greek gods and
goddesses that we know in the real world
are known as the olympians in marvel
comics and it's very dissimilar to how
the norse gods
and goddesses are known as the
asgardians
the olympians live in a pocket dimension
known as olympus uh you know it looks a
lot like the mount olympus of legend uh
and a lot of their history and hierarchy
in the comics mimics that of our real
real world greek mythology that makes
sense so it's a lot like what we're
learning about on moon night with like
the egyptian gods and the any end right
and just like the asgardians like we
said uh marvel comics was like oh these
stories are already great let's kind of
pour them over and explain them through
our own comic ways right and we're super
excited to have the pantheon of gods
expand in the mcu uh but we had a little
film by the name of eternals come out
last year which seemed to establish some
of these space androids as part of
earth's mythology specifically greek
mythology so how is all this going to
mesh together jessica let's see if we
can figure that out by going through
some of the eternals and see where the
confusion might lie uh and let's begin
with the head
of the the new head of eternal of the
internals here on earth
cersei oh she's the boss now jackson of
the boss she is definitely the head up
but now she she was sucked away well
yeah yeah she's on her way to go talk to
arisham and get she is she is the she's
the leader the captain she's the captain
now i'm the come to know she looked at
she looked at ajax's dead body and was
like
the captain now
these are my eternals i shouldn't do
that voice that's terrible
this is my i can do it you can do it
jessica
please stop i can't i can't but hey
so when she was around during like uh
early history dealing with human
civilization you know she was helping
humans develop culture with her
transfiguration abilities while the
other offensive-based eternals would
wipe out deviants right she'd usually
let them do the fighting
she'd hang back and like change things
into other things
she has a counterpart in greek mythology
of course cersei spelled differently
c-i-r-c-e and cersei is a minor goddess
sometimes referred to as like a witch
and she's most famous for her role in
the odyssey homer's the odyssey right
she falls in love with odysseus when he
lands on her island and he doesn't want
her she doesn't want him to leave uh and
she has this habit of when people wrong
her she turns them into animals that
kind of transfiguration ability right
yeah yeah odysseus and his man they wash
up on the shore because they're on their
way home and they're like oh let's take
a little break here oh look at these
animals running around and they come to
find out those were people those are
people oh god i got it so in greek
mythology like cersei she's like i said
she's a minor goddess she's pretty far
down from like zeus and his children
right um and she was known she was like
a goddess known for her abilities to
make potions and work with herbs and she
also had this magic wand that could like
change people okay so this is more like
our cersei yeah except for the staff
right right so that's how like the
similarities lie between our the cersei
of the eternals and like real world
mythology cersei okay now the olympians
don't really have their own version of
cersei in the comics so there's not
going to be much incongruence there
right in fact marvel comics has even
retconned the comic version of cersei so
that in the comics she is the
inspiration uh for cersei's action in
the odyssey oh she like inspired homer
by what she was doing
they can do that so well right right
they can do that so well and i'll give
them that for eternals and for moon
night i'm just like
yeah
historically it links up it makes sense
now it makes sense we all love a little
crossover and this is the most major
crossover that we can be given is
history and fictional right right
and so yeah so i think when the
olympians show up in the mcu they're not
gonna be mad about cersei no she's not
pretending to be one of theirs uh not
one of their main ones anyways she's
like a lesser character so she won't
they won't be mad about it they'll
probably fall in love with her they
probably will who wouldn't fall in love
with cersei huh let me tell you jeremy
chan
marry me
if you're watching this randomly i know
some celebrities do for some reason i'm
i'm here baby i'm here if also who else
watches us the founder of reddit um more
specifically serena williams if you're
watching this or your husband the
founder of reddit serena if you're lying
in bed with your husband you're watching
this uh call jessica i don't know sorry
husband you're cool serena please mama
baby come here come on my favorite place
so cersei's cool i think no problem
there that'll make sense but let's get
to the the big one that i'm sure is on
everyone's mind
fina right fina
as confirmed by sprite in the eternals
films uh the eternal we know athena was
known to the people of ancient greece as
the goddess athena
thanks to her work defending athens from
the deviants so that's like a literal
translation right yeah these ancient
greeks they see a goddess what they
assume to be a goddess fighting these
monsters and they're like oh that's a
goddess and then sprite's like yeah and
her name's athena
uh and i think the story is because
she's defending athens they named her
after athens
in the eternals like mythology right yes
uh now here's where the big problem
arises right we all know of athena yeah
from like you know uh greek mythology
and there is already an olympian known
as athena in marvel comics she's the
daughter of zeus and she was worshipped
by the ancient greeks and the ancient
romans and in the comics the city of
athens was actually named after athena
that athena yeah the olympian version of
athena okay right so it's like there was
a contest between her and poseidon uh
and the people of the city chose athena
and so they named the city athens after
her
[Music]
so yeah that's gonna be a little bit of
a problem right because you know the
olympians are gonna show up and athena's
gonna look at fina and be like what are
you doing this is something that they'll
have to fix once they get to that hurdle
right but
i guess i guess in the movies they don't
really have to address
well because remember sprite is talking
to
dane whitman right when he's in the he's
in the uh museum waiting for his
girlfriend to get finished with her
class he's looking at a statue and he
mentions athena and then like sprite's
like
it's athena and they never get the face
right you know something like that
uh and he's like what are you talking
about girl well i'm saying that zeus's
athena doesn't need to be brought up
really in the movies well i mean she's
she's a big pretty big part of like the
olympians right i know it's a huge
please don't skip it but i feel like
yeah well they made such a point of it
in the eternals film how could they not
address it so maybe that could be the
joke that could be the bit like
eventually when we do see athena she's
like
well i'm wondering if my name is that or
if they do something like they did with
hella right when she's when they had to
kind of wreck con the infinity gauntlet
that was it sitting in odin's vault she
walks by at ragnarok and she's like oh
it's a fake it's a fake
right are they gonna have the real
athena be like in a museum and be like
that's not me that's that dumb robot
that was pretending to be me
i hate her right well i guess who's more
so the actual zeus
zeus is athena is she more powerful than
arthane well she's a god i get that but
is she like a warrior like she is a war
she's like a powerful warrior she's very
strong she has all the ability all the
olympians have like base god abilities
right yeah and so do the sort of the
eternals but the eternals are robots and
they have to suffer through programming
right that's true so oh that'd be sad so
the gods have more agency in a lot of
ways i could see them doing the museum
type of trip and being like oh this is
the fake one this is the robot version
of me like right right okay i could see
that that'd be so sad because it would
just make all of athena's storyline kind
of
she's already got some issues with like
remembering the destruction of other
planets and stuff like i think your way
would make sense and be fun but i think
over like i think they're just gonna act
like zeus is a thing that doesn't exist
well we don't know why the olympians
haven't been coming down to earth right
so far only the asgardians are coming to
earth and moon knight has showed us that
the enia doesn't come here anymore they
don't come to our realm they don't want
to deal with us because we don't worship
them enough maybe the olympians feel the
same way like because greek mythology
has become so passe and is not really
worshipped anymore they're like we have
no
we don't even want to be on earth it's
not fun we would rather hang out with
aliens and like other gods and stuff
this place so
that's right it sucks let's leave that's
me we out this [ __ ] we can't actually
look at the comics to get an idea of how
the olympians and the internals might
interact right so in the comics zeus
winds up discovering olympia
which is a little confusing olympus is
the pocket dimension where the olympians
live the greek gods olympia
was the city in the comic books that was
like the home base of the eternals
this is the pocket pocket dimensions
zeus discovers olympia and he goes there
with his daughter athena right and they
meet up with zoros who is the leader of
the eternals in the comic books and his
daughter azura and they kind of come to
this realization that they
all look similar and have similar powers
like zeus and zoros and then athena and
azura so they decide to make like this
kind of non-interference pact between
the eternals and the olympians and the
way this works right the way this works
is that the eternal the eternals would
act as heralds on earth on behalf of the
greek gods
for certain occasions right got it yes
so they kind of made this deal like we
won't interfere with each other we won't
call each other out but the gods are
basically every now and then eternals
pretend like you're us pretend like
you're acting on our behalf right and so
to solidify this pact azura changed her
name to fina to make it very easy to
like do the kind of crossover right uh
and this is all according to the
official handbook of the marvel universe
volume two that came out in 1980 that
came out in 1986
so the comics have addressed this issue
of like the eternals are very similar to
the greek gods and we need to make them
get along how are we going to do that so
do we think they're going to do
something similar with the olympians in
the mcu they'll they'll have said like
oh don't worry thousands of years ago we
hashed that [ __ ] out
well that would give more and i'll give
so much more depth to make other things
to be like well great now what other
gods are just mimics of others
like them yeah it's like having the
avatar in moonlight it's like being like
yeah i'm down here but like i'm not
really there i'm up here because i can't
come right down i don't have time i'm
too busy i'm zoos well that makes sense
right they kind of portray in this very
short clip we got to see right olympus
look in the trailer looks like a baller
place like it looks like disneyland
right it looks like a party and there's
all these shows it's bright and it's
happy and maybe like the olympians were
like we just want to party we don't want
to defend earth anymore and that's when
the gorge comes through and just slowly
yeah exactly because like he like maybe
he like off uh outsourced their job to
the eternals he saw the eternals were
already on earth already doing all this
hard work and they see maybe like and
maybe the olympians know their robots
honestly gore could be like
why are you making that why why are you
making these robots work for you
christian bale's coming through
yeah
i think that's a good way to like kind
of hash this out is be like oh the
olympians saw that the robots were
already doing it they're like they're
fine they're fine we don't need to go
and they're literally just partying
they're just partying they're just
partying yeah 100 well and also in the
comics the olympians and the asgardians
they like fight a lot they like go head
to head because they're kind of very
similar so maybe they're like also too
busy dealing with the asgardians they're
like we got to deal with these other
guys
made sure they were gone and now they
came back to another small town like
yeah we're just wait forget about it
yeah forget about it i still i i see
yours more so happening i'm still on
that train that that scene that we saw
with the back of zeus's head is
literally on just one of those ships
that are coming in that's like on a
party cruise and it's just like a
theatrical performance and the
background isn't just like just like a
drop of like
look at the skies and zeus and the greek
gods or whatever and i'm just like this
ain't real none of this is real no this
is real this is an actor it's gonna be
christian bale playing zeus right uh but
yours seems more plausible well i like
your reasoning though that gore is gonna
see what they're just partying and not
doing their job and be like you gotta
die
you gotta die literally triggered is
gonna be like my family my people
crossed deserts right for you you guys
are just partying yeah you guys are just
partying doing shots yeah taking shots
off the ice luge come on gore's like
yeah give me that
family's dead
[Laughter]
give it up
yeah let's hope that makes sense right
all right well let's take a moment to
talk about hercules the neglected son of
zeus
hercules hercules
he had a lot of appearances in marvel
comics over the years most often
interacting with thor sometimes battling
with him
sometimes battling against him we used
to be best buddies
and now we're not i wish you would tell
me
they kind of like you know they're both
kind of forgotten sons or spoiled sons
who like have dad issues so like they
would fight a lot and uh like sometimes
like odin would pit hercules against
thor to teach him a lesson and like all
this crazy stuff i can't i don't need
this i don't need this i need this weird
daddy yeah but hercules he also had a
stint as an avenger like he was an
avenger for a while and most recently he
fought alongside the guardians of the
galaxy in the comic books like last year
you could argue that the eternal
gilgamesh shares a lot of similarities
with hercules they're both very strong
they're both powerful warriors but
gilgamesh has a mythological counterpart
in the hero
gilgamesh wow that makes sense right
who's he's a he's part of mesopotamian
mythology so i don't think there'll be
much confusion there between like
gilgamesh and
but do you think we will see hercules
we have to address this kind of show we
have to address them eventually if they
all get slaughtered i want hercules to
be the last one right i want hercules i
want to be the last of the olympians
yeah lastly i want him to be the last
one left i want him to either not be
there or be the only one successfully
that gets away right uh but i also think
that scene wouldn't be addressed until
the post credits like it wouldn't you
wouldn't see it then but he's also like
half have god yeah he is half guys so
it's even better storylining yeah he's
got a lot of deuce
you know just wasn't faithful to his
wife
uh most of his children have different
mothers and yeah hercules was like not
allowed in to olympus and like kept out
and it gives them a lot of resentment i
think we talked about this briefly maybe
me or me and zack or me and john someone
that works at the rock stars about how
uh if hercules did show up he would have
more in common with um chris pratt's
character right yeah being like we're
both have guns like right i'm off guard
and then thor's just standing there like
you guys stop being friends like this
i hate this yeah yeah i hope that their
history exists like thor and hercules
history because it would be
hercules seems like the one person to
make thor look like a punk right yeah
exactly the way like thor shows up and
now like star-lord's like oh nobody
likes me anymore like i could see
hercules being mad for thor where he he
feels like second banana to hercules
because he's like this big tough dude
why are your hercules well i want them
to just bring the rock back
let the rocks hercules be cannon and
bring him in
and just have the rock be hercules i
love the rock would be playing black
atom and
we're going to play hercules he's like i
want to play gods i mean don't be so
strong if you don't want to play gods
all the time
he's built to play a god in a movie yeah
i mean i i really hope it does show up
because they've already established
right that like kingo was hanging out
with thor and they would party so i i
think hercules has got to show up even
if it's just for a minute maybe they're
holding in their back pocket for later
if you're going with thor and you have
all this history it's like you're gonna
have to address this eventually and
they're trying to address it they're
gonna address it i hope so okay well
let's talk about makari now right hey
girl my girl makari fan favorite for
eternal definitely
like came affirmative on top for sure
they were like the best part really
makari is of course the speedster of the
eternals and she has a comparable
olympian and hermes the messenger of the
gods right uh he was another secret son
of zeus uh who was well renowned for his
speed like when his mom was trying to
take care of him on earth he would keep
like running out and stealing stealing
cows and stuff uh many times in the
comics hermes and makari get confused
for each other especially during the
trojan war
so if we see a hermes dashing around
olympus do you think he's gonna have
something to say about makari getting
credit for a lot of his actions okay so
my whole thing and i'm not a mythology
expert
let me say that first is hermes really
gonna be as fast as makari well they
have like raced in the comics a lot and
i think they're pretty much
terrible in speed right i just mekari
has done some incredible things in the
comics in terms of speed it might be one
of the fastest people in the comics
maybe the only one faster being like the
runner who i think the runner never
slows down ever and can just like run
through time and stuff that's why makari
might be faster than her i think she's
both different
also if hermes hasn't come down and is
just literally playing messenger for the
gods but he's been everywhere else yeah
yeah so i guess that doesn't really
translate to like who would win in a
fight it's more so like i'd be rooting
for makari
like a lot of times in the comics uh you
know because the eternals were there
throughout history they would do stuff
and the people would just be like oh
that's hermes because i know who hermes
is yeah like the people of ancient
greece had no idea who makari was what
is it and they both had like helmets and
stuff so they were often confused but i
don't think like hermes really cared
that's also true he just was like i
still get the credit even if it's
someone else doing it yeah hermes is
like we're both fast right yeah i feel
like with hercules and thor it'd be
really much like a show-off competition
like who's the best but with her with
hermes and makari would be like
we both do this we both do the first run
faster we both run fast look at us
running fast look at us look at us
running fast
not me running fast from war
that's what you're doing hermes i see
you then of course we have the eternal
fast dos the great builder uh he too has
a greek god counterpart in hephaestus
hephaestus
i always say i like hephaestus we're
going to go with hephaestus the olympian
hephaestus was worshipped by the ancient
greeks and romans as the patriot god of
blacksmiths and he made all the weapons
and armor for the other greek gods in
olympus right that was his job
hephaestus was another son of zeus but
was actually the son of zeus and hera
so good job zeus for having at least one
kid with your wife
uh but
hera tossed hephaestus out of olympus as
a child because he was crippled and he
was raised by someone else some of the
stories have it being like zeus actually
got him out to protect him from hera i
don't know either way they kicked him
out
he's raised by someone else but he
eventually makes his way back to olympus
so he gets he gets put in with the other
olympians as far as i can tell he
doesn't have much interaction with
fastos the eternal in the comics other
than like fastest would get mistaken for
hephaestus much like makari would get
mistaken for hermes when they were like
doing stuff in greece i think this would
be a case where like hephaestus would be
pissed for fast dose getting all the
credit good credit for like building all
my [ __ ] yeah i would be absolutely and
then maybe he saw the nuke go off and he
was like oh that was yeah yeah that was
right yeah yeah that was fast
that's awesome
that's also true we need to keep track
of how many time that he unfortunately
killed a bunch of people right of in the
name of
war building stuff i guess i don't know
oh yeah and also he wasn't trying he was
like okay first off he's building stuff
he was uh hired to build stuff right and
he thought like it just like the mindset
of a god of being like i'm doing this
for us and it's like i didn't think you
were going to do it that way yeah i mean
splitting the atom was important for
uh human scientific development but also
incredibly dangerous in the wrong hands
we learned it too soon too quick too
quick too quick to learn that so how
many things has he made that actually
damaged the world where athestus would
be like
well i don't want that because then it's
also they're still gods so they're gods
because they're being worshipped so if
you're being worshipped for the wrong
reasons or not like worship for the
wrong seasons but if you're doing the
wrong things it's like what's gonna it's
gonna make people stop believing that
god and be like i don't trust this one i
think you're right because like
hephaestus is mainly building stuff for
other gods yeah and i bet he's pissed
that like fastest is sharing stuff with
humans
and if especially if that gets human
development beyond the point of
believing in gods
then like maybe the olympians lose power
because of it because they don't have
the worshiping power in it yeah that's
true that's 100 people but i could see
him being really pissed at fast us for
being like yeah why why were you helping
the humans so much do you think that's
how we do develop them out of believing
in us that's not what we do we keep them
in their place there's the first officer
that's not what we do
uh
what did they say i help those who help
themselves yeah yeah and it's just true
hephaestus gets away with it because
he's giving it to the god so it's like
once it's in their hands it's in their
hands whatever happens after that it's
the gods yeah you can't blame humans for
what the humans did it's like well you
handed the humans this and this is what
the humans did so this is how i try to
get out of situations i'm like i'm just
human
i like it i'm just human i make mistakes
i make mistakes finally we'll discuss
two more
of the eternals that kind of have greek
mythology counterparts you have icarus
and ajax right uh
both the eternals icarus and ajax have
counterparts in greek mythology but
they're not gods so they don't really
have like olympian counterparts you know
what i mean uh icarus is similar to
icarus the son of daedalus who built the
labyrinth uh and of course icarus is
known for flying too close to the sun
with his wax wings and they melted and
then our android icarus flew into the
sun and is maybe dead maybe not who
knows he's still alive probably still
alive um a robot walking on the sun
because the eternal icarus right he
could fly people thought he was icarus
it's a good comparison
and then the former eternals leader ajax
is similar to the powerful greek warrior
known as ajax the great but again ajax
the great was not a god he was just like
another figure he shows up in the iliad
so i don't think the olympians are going
to be pissed about icarus and ajax
they're not taking any of the thunder
anything they're going to be like why
were these two-year leaders yeah yeah
why did you choose yeah
they're gonna be so confused so that
won't be that won't be a problem there
at all i think that's fine how do we
think the similarities between the
eternals and the olympians are gonna be
explained away in the mcu how are they
gonna explain this in thor love and
thunder what you said really resonated
in me of like when they do come down the
bigger ones they'll just like like the
museum of like oh this is my dog it's
fake it's a fake it's a fake
i i think that would be the way to
handle it of being like
no we had them come to earth to play us
for you guys i mean i understand that
it's kind of like a trick but it's like
it it would give it give us more reason
also to be like oh if we thought those
guys were strong these guys are stronger
yeah like and if we're already seeing
that in moonlight with the avatars it's
just one level from that so you're
you're just just it's just a little bit
just a little bit of going higher yeah i
love this idea we kind of came up with
where it's like yeah they don't care
what the earthlings believe like who
cares if they thought an eternal was a
god it's like it still works for them
they got bigger fish to fry they don't
care what us puny earthlings are doing
there's kicking back eating ambrosia
drinking nectar having the time of their
take in those shots until gore the
goddess
how did you get tickets you gotta have
reservations to come to olympus what are
you doing that's the first thing hermes
says oh you're not on this list i can't
let you through i think it's immediately
like oh what about this yeah
it takes that circle here's my
invitation oh have you ever been shanked
because that's what's gonna happen
do you think the olympians are going to
stick around post 411 thunder or do you
think they'll all get wiped out i think
they all get like wiped out except for
that's i want that's a theory a very big
theory a rogue theory on big question
but also nonetheless a theory i really
want to happen um you can have all of
them in there but it doesn't show how
important they are if there's like a
million of them whereas you can have
just one right and i think that um
rick rider like of just being like this
is the last man left that has the mind
literally this entire
their entire people civilization so i
think having that one person be hercules
is such a good idea and hercules is so
fun you can have him do all the things
against any of the strong it doesn't
just have to be uh thor it could also be
like any of the other eternals like he
could fight harry styles
hey come over here let me choke you
hey come over here let me rip out those
robot guts i i think hercules has to be
the last one standing okay i like that i
like that it would be f or athena i
guess the athena one would be fun the
way you said it maybe tina and hercules
can
hook up and they just form a life
together oh that's what that's all i
want and i want gilgamesh to come back
is that a spoiler did he die yeah i
forgot
he was actually i know it was a good
foreign that's right you are a monster
i'm a monster i can't believe gilgamesh
was my favorite part of that damn movie
i think my mind got wiped too much by no
way home i think i forget too much oh
that's true
[Laughter]
we got some merch for y'all we've got
merch for you keep your eyes peeled for
the release of some very cool multiverse
of madness merch over at new
rockstarsmerch.com
especially watch out for the limited
edition latest obsession
shirt i don't think we have one that's
normally next to me but not today but
you can look it up online at new
rockstars.com and buy it they always
knock the design out of the park for
those shirts and buying one directly
supports us me and brandon here at new
rockstars and before we dive into our
bite size questions next let's give a
little shout out to our sponsors that
help us bring big question to you big
wireless providers always get you with a
catch the cool thing about mint mobile
and their premium wireless starting at
just 15 bucks a month is that there
isn't one mint mobile secret sauce is
that they're the first company to sell
wireless service online only they cut
out the cost of retail stores and pass
those sweet savings directly to you and
me
we've got a few folks at new rock stars
who switched them at mobile including
our editor riley and myself who loves it
me and riley both use mitt mobile and we
save so much money he kept his phone and
his number and is saving a bunch of
money every month for everyone who hates
their phone bill mint mobile offers
premium wireless for just fifteen
dollars a month
fifteen dollars a month mit mobile gives
you the best rate whether you're buying
for one or for your family and at mint
families start at two lines all plans
come with unlimited talk and text plus
high speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5g network to get your
new wireless plan for just 15 a month
that is a good price and get the plan
shipped to your door for free go to
mintmobile.com
big q that's mintmobile.com
big q it'll probably be under here cut
your wireless bill to 15 a month at
midmobile.com
big q a little life hack that super-rich
families have used to safeguard their
money for decades is their art
collections the rockefeller's art
collection sold for over 800 million
dollars in 2019 which was far less than
they spent building it so what if you
could invest in the same art they did
and use this wealth hack for yourself
now you can with masterworks it's the
first platform where you can invest in
masterpieces by legends like picasso
banksy and basqua did i say that right
basqua that shows how little i know
about art but the people at masterworks
know a ton about art they let you invest
in just a portion of these paintings so
you can get all the upside of art as an
investment without the high cost it's
also pretty cool to say you've invested
in some banksy masterworks was founded
by a top art collector and tech
entrepreneurs and they've been hustling
to gather a bunch of cool art so you can
get in the game with all those
billionaires this sounds like a genius
idea to us and we're not the only ones
as over 400 000 people have signed up
for masterworks the big question
audience can skip their wait list just
go to masterworks dot art slash big
question and see important regulation a
disclosure at masterworks dot io slash
cd again that's masterworks dot art
slash big question all right and now we
are ready for our bite size ooh bite
size
questions
hey brandon uh as by manscaping pancakes
on discord how long would nebula have
survived on the benetar with no food or
water if they had never been rescued ah
okay so we're talking about uh this is
an end game at the very beginning of end
game if you remember it's just tony and
nebula they're on the benetar after the
destruction of the planet they're
waiting they can't get the ship started
it's they're slowly running out of food
and water what's gonna happen right well
while a lot of nebula's body has been
replaced by machinery we do know that
she needs to eat still right because if
you remember uh in guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 she claims to be hungry and
she tries to eat that yarrow root and
they keep going like oh it's not ripe
yet uh and if she was just like faking
it i don't think she would try so hard
to eat the root she was trying really
she was definitely hungry right she
needs food she still has organic parts
to her and if she needs food she
probably needs water as well right yeah
so we would assume she can't just like
live forever on a robot parts so an end
game when they're on that immobile
spaceship the benetar it's clear that
her cybernetic half will enable her to
last longer than tony right remember
tony tries to give her water and she's
like no no you're all human you need to
take that water
don't be wasting it on me now i looked
into it and there's some different info
out there as to how long a human can go
without food or water but it seems like
a few survival guides seem to indicate
that the average human can go 30 to 40
days without food that's uh impossible
that's a long time right i could barely
go a couple hours without that's not
real it's false no way no
i will literally i will i will kill him
i will literally eat yeah i will start
eating this [ __ ] yeah i will say day
three i'm gonna eat whoever i'm with
let's just say that
thankfully i'm hungry okay
three i'm gonna eat something i'm gonna
eat somewhere
day three we need to start eating some
of the crew i recommend we start tommy
he's young and succulent ah i mean
yellowjackets showed us we can't go that
long without food
but when it comes to water like you
might be able to go wild without food
not me but you might be able to
but when it comes to water that's a very
dire situation right a human needs water
within like two to four days there have
certainly been situations where humans
have gone longer than that but plenty
people die of dehydration after two to
four days and i would not recommend
trying to push back past that point okay
someone watching a big question right
now i was like yeah yeah so that's you
don't know me you don't know me
that's tony right two to four days
without water for tony's gonna kill him
now nebula is originally a luphemoid
which is a humanoid alien species and
now while we don't know the water and
food needs for a lupimoid right uh
whatever parts of nebula's body are
still organic lupamoid
it's going to need food and water at
some point right so i would guess that
nebula could maybe survive twice as long
as tony with her metabolism being slower
and her having like she's getting there
is power in her robot parts remember she
she was able to like wire herself up and
use the lasers on the ship right uh so
she has internal power which maybe could
be converted into
you know
caloric energy or something but like
that's gonna run out and her organic
parts are gonna die without water so i
my my best answer for this is like if
tony can go to two to four days without
water she can go four to eight days
without water and eventually she's gonna
die too so if captain marvel hadn't
showed up uh and saved them she they
both would have died eventually all
right i'll do that pretty pretty
depressing but that is different that's
the best that's a really good question
also because it's like oh yeah she could
probably technically go a little bit
longer but not fully she's not full yeah
she's got organic parts and part of her
brain to store organic is going to die
away and yeah you know they're well yeah
she's and also even if she did have like
a robot stomach it's like she still
needs the power of the human being
yeah yeah
they're just gonna die okay second
question is from sam on discord if you
could pick your ideal lineup for mcu's
initial x-men team who would the members
be and when you asked me this question i
was a stupid idiot and i kept putting in
people that were technically on the team
for maybe like 20 minutes like mystique
uh you could do that i think that's fair
that's what i well and then okay i was
talking to someone and they were
immediately like that was only in the
movies and i was like uh well okay well
this is our this is the movies right the
mcu is the movie that is true we're
gonna make our dream team okay for the
initial lineup and i think to make it
fair we're gonna go by like initial
x-men team rules right okay so you're
gonna pick five team members for your
x-men team professor x is gonna be there
he's all-time qb right he's the leader
clearly who are the five x-men that that
show up first and these could be any
mutants you want i said well this is
initial so this is like the first this
is the the introduction
of the other movie you only get five
yeah you're normal
mcu proper you only get five extra storm
has to be one boom storm has to be one
for me okay oh the second that has to be
there is beast okay i think you still
need that person is your beast
transformed or is he human being or is
he beast beast cramps we don't got time
for human beings i don't got time for
humanity get out of here okay give that
hair a beast and then these are the
three that i was like these are tough
these are these can uh kind of
kind of come and go darwin and this is
me coming up darwin
because he after he did not get the
rightful death he deserved whoops
whoopsie i started getting so into
darwin they did himself he's like put
this man back in there he did have dirty
give him give it back give it back now
put that thing back where it came from
or so help me okay and then i did iceman
because it's also very fun very fun and
this is where i'm a little
it's between rogue or gambit for me and
i think i'd probably lean gambit oh
we need to see a gambit we need to see a
live action game so i think it's just
get channing tatum back in here yeah he
wants to be he wants to be gambling we
want to see gambit dancing yeah
and i just oh gambling like crazy oh
baby okay that's a good team here's
here's mine team okay cyclops i mean you
can't you can't my boy scott aka
aka slim summers he gets a bad rap all
the time right you kind of have cyclones
you can and you're so good you don't and
you do he's so good um
you can you can do them right you can do
them maybe that's it maybe that's it i
need to disattack
no
well the astonishing x-men run that was
written by redacted we're not going to
say his name uh
redacted scott summers and the
astonishing annexmen is awesome and is
so well done and i think you i think you
can get there again okay second jean
grey i mean you gotta have g great
i either get emma frost or jean grey
okay then then i will take jean grey
they don't need to be together they
don't need to be in a relationship but
you gotta have both of them you gotta
have both of them okay now my third this
is gonna be controversial this is going
to be a this is an mcu swirl please
don't magneto
no that's fine start magneto as a good
guy that's 100 younger than xavier not
contemporaries
xavier is almost like a father to him
right so we're not doing first class
we're not doing first class you're going
before i'm going before this this is mcu
and you can rewrite the rules right
start eric lyncher off as like a good
guy yeah who just like can't take it
he's like kylo ren baby he breaks bad
you know 100 that's my third that's my
throne okay i'm completely fine with
that for my girl jubilee
people hate on jubilee but she is strong
she is powerful
i love jubilee
get her in there i want to see some
jubilee i want to see let's make it
happen let's get some jubilees going
okay now for my fifth one
this is a tough one the fifth one and
she's your fifth also imagine the team
you just get you i know you chose a lot
of people that don't really work well
together i know well they're they're
gonna have to learn to get along that's
that's the heart of the x-men you gotta
learn to be a team you gotta learn to go
on you gotta learn to play together you
gotta learn to be nice i think for my
fifth team member i mean you took storm
i like storm a lot yeah storm has to so
dormant beast for me always have to i
think you kind of teased this earlier
and you didn't go with it so i'm going
to steal it now juggernaut i did say
this
have xavier's brother on the team yes
you know and you know so he's got two
potential people that could break bad
maybe they they break off from the
original team and form the brotherhood
of mutants right so yeah that's that's
my initial run i wanted to be clear i
did mention it she did try and take it
bad people off my team i thought we were
doing it
i'm an idiot and i [ __ ] and i no you
have a good team i like you
when it comes to like who you want to
marry in the x-men universe it is
juggernaut is my number one and then
beast is my number two okay and then
storm
we all want to max
but those are good teams and i would
watch we can't wait for the x-men to
show up in the mcu but now it's time for
oh yeah oh sorry i forgot we have our
box of scraps all right ready yes the
box of scraps boxes
escape with a bunch of scraps
oh my god what is that you want me to
give you guys you give us the boxes when
have you ever encountered your
doppelganger in real life mine i've
never encountered but they're i've never
encountered my doppelganger they're very
much more successful than me
so my doppelganger existed in a weird
time period if you guys remember the
first purge film that came oh absolutely
there was a young man in that purge film
uh who i guess bears a slight
resemblance to me and then i think he
was also on parenthood the tv show yeah
but i would be i would be like in a
grocery store and a a middle-aged woman
would like look at me
and then like think for a second or
think i'm the boy from parenthood who
has asperger's but i'm clearly older
than that child they would look
concerned like are you okay and then
it's like i'm not the kid from the show
i keep going to the purge but that movie
came from like 2012. yeah yeah that's
what i'm talking about i'm much older
than that but i was already much older
than that child at the point but they
were like this looks like you as a
little kid
i also i also get told specific i know
it was so weird and it was just like the
the purge was hot when it first came out
right and so for those two months it was
just happening all the time and it's
like i'm not this kid uh and then i get
told i sound like vince vaughn i don't
hear it but i get told that like all the
time so those are my doppelgangers
vaughn the actor
i'm thinking oh oh
oh you do
oh you i can't hear it because you can't
hear your own voice you know it's in
your head yeah it sounds weird oh i was
thinking vin diesel and i was like you
sound nothing like that
family family my doppelganger is really
hard to find and if any one of you in
the comments immediately say cabbage
patch doll i'm gonna fight you because i
see it we all see it but we don't need
to acknowledge it anymore but i did
recently find out and this was via
someone in twitter that i look like
keenan thompson
and um
it's i
it's very true if the editors could just
bring up you both got great cheeks a
great smile it's not the eyes don't look
at the eyes but it's the cheeks cheeks
the lips
we both have nose i think we both have
the same shade as skin keenan if you're
watching this i would love some of that
money
just on my way through a little bit my
way that show i could be your stun
double i can't i can't i'm gonna be a
stunt double i could be your stun double
in the show keenan
and that
is it for our episode of big questions
so fun to be in person in a studio it's
so weird i hope nobody's watching this
and being like i hate them in a studio
put them back on the little computer oh
you better love us in a studio because
you're going to get a ton more of us in
studio literally you guys are going to
get us now you're going to get us in the
break room that comes out tomorrow the
break room break room yeah break room
that comes out tomorrow uh starring
everybody here at new rock stars yeah
yeah be sure to tune into the break room
it's our new daily streaming show live
from new rockstars headquarters it
starts this week right here on our
youtube channel check us out live hop in
that chat talk to us we can't wait to
bring the show to you we've been working
real hard on it and we're so excited to
premiere it for you guys
and thank you brandon for joining me on
this episode follow him at grin and
barrack follow me at lulu underscore
clemens follow new rockstars here on
youtube and on all social media
platforms make sure to hit that
notification bell turn it on swipe right
on us uh oh and also check us out on
tumblr yeah that's right we're on tumblr
now on tumblr and guess who's on that
tumblr
me and i know you some of you guys are
probably like oh man i don't even have
tumblr anymore get back on it get back
on it you just have to log in i still
have like seven blogs and now eight
because of the new rock stars it's great
you can ask me questions and i will
answer them to my best degree you can
ask me where eric voss is and i'll tell
you and you can also keep the
conversation going on at our new
rockstars discord yeah check it out in
the comments click on the link join the
discord come say hi thanks for tuning in
tuning in to big question check out
newrockstarsmerch.com
[Music]
you